hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
it's no secret that I like Android pure
I've gravitated towards devices running
stock Android for the past couple of
months or a year - and there are a
couple of other devices that have come
out for people with the same preference
as me but the Nexus release which is
roughly once a year tends to be the one
that we wait for the most so this is the
newest one this is the Nexus 6 and it's
basically a big Moto X running stock
Android no no like a really really
really big Moto X running stock Android
it's kind of hard to show exactly how
big this phone is since everyone has
different size hands and everyone's
coming from a phone of a different size
but if you've ever seen some of the
larger phones on the market like here it
is completely concealing the Samsung
Galaxy Note 4 which means the larger
footprint it has bigger dimensions in
every single way it's also pretty
similar in size to the iPhone 6 plus at
least in terms of height but it's much
wider and the iPhone is super thin while
the Nexus 6 is a lot more sloping and
rounded this is actually the first phone
I've had that doesn't fit in the cup
holder in my car I've used some like
really wide phones before the oneplus
one the Galaxy Note 4 really wide but
this one's just freaking huge and I
think the Galaxy mega is the only one
that's been this massive but yeah the
hardware is essentially a larger version
of that moto X with a couple of minor
changes which are all good I think I
personally think the Moto X was already
one of the better design phones of the
year and all the changes made are an
improvement over that already great
phone so besides being much bigger you
also get the dimple from the older moto
X 2 years ago which I actually think was
better it's a nice soft indentation with
a subtle Motorola logo not the off-color
[ __ ] stamp and the word Nexus is
engraved and filled with metal or at
least some shiny material that looks
like metal on the back it has the same
power and volume buttons from that Moto
X the ridged power button on the side
and it's excellent and very clicky and
tactile so these are excellent buttons
actually liked that a lot
except now they're in the middle of the
phone so pretty far down and that's
actually really good for holding it and
pressing them with one handed use again
you're probably not going to use this
phone with one hand very often but I
think they're in the right spot and you
get the same met
band all the way around the phone which
is great for the way it feels in the
hand I like using the word rigid to
describe it this is probably the best
hardware for this new software which
I'll talk about in a bit but basically
the display sort of melts over on to the
sides so it's not a sharp corner like
the note for the glass is curved at the
very edges so you can drag your finger
on and off the display with no problem
which means you're dragging things in
from the side bars that are all over
Android 5.0 and yet you still have that
metal Bend to grip on to when holding
the phone and that part isn't slippery
so it's a nice combination of round and
flat now the back of the phone is round
2 so that means it's not going to sit
still on any flat surface which drives
me crazy a little bit because basically
I text while my phone is flat on a desk
all the time but that's basically
impossible with the Nexus 6 the back
isn't even that slippery it's a soft
touch material but if you touch it at
all it's going to start spinning and
rocking and rotating wherever is sitting
so that felt less elegant to me but it
probably won't be that big of a deal for
most people and the Nexus 6 also gets
dual front-facing speakers they protrude
a little bit so you can't set it flat
the other way either but something
that's we didn't get that at all in the
Moto X we only had one speaker
front-facing before here we have two so
we get that stereo image of very loud
clear directional sound from all your
media and all your games it's not quite
boom sound in terms of volume or quality
honestly the lowest two or three notches
of volume are basically silent and the
highest to both sound like the max
volume but overall it's much louder and
clearer than any rear-facing or downward
facing speakers yet they still manage to
keep the bezels pretty small and the
funny thing about these bezels so they
aren't the same size at all as you can
see which is funny because we're used to
that symmetrical forehead and chin look
but it's a bit smaller on the bottom
bezel than the top kind of like the
phone is also a little bit thinner on
the bottom than the top due to that big
sloping curve but these small bezels and
front-facing speakers allow for a
massive 5.9 six inch quad HD AMOLED
display and that right there is the
biggest difference versus the Moto X
this display is crazy good and very very
sharp at 493 ppi and it's overall really
good probably one of the best in any
smartphone not the best I would still
give that to the Galaxy Note 4 right now
but I mean it's very bright super sharp
has those pitch black blacks and awesome
saturation and contrast ratios from
being an AMOLED display viewing angles
are pretty good except for the extremes
where it starts to rainbow out but
that's really at the far extremes and
colors are pretty good except when you
turn the brightness all the way down
which turns the display noticeably super
pink like very pink since there's so
much bright white in Android 5.0 you
notice this stuff when you're using a
phone at night it makes it so obvious
how salmon-colored things look but some
might argue that's actually a feature
it's better for your eyes no it's not a
feature it's just not quite as color
accurate as some other panels it's still
definitely beautiful though I mean the
display overall contributes to a great
hardware package the Nexus 6 is quite a
nice phone to hold it's technically
water-resistant the back is soft touch
the whole build is like I said rigid
with that metal again it's really really
really big I know everyone's probably
told this to you already but seriously
it's a huge phone so that gives you a
huge canvas for Google to play on with
the software and of course this guy is
running stock Android 5.0 lollipop and
Android on this phone has so much new I
mean I feel like the more I use it the
more I uncover new features I mean you
just kind of find new things all the
time like literally the other day I
visited droid life and of course the
status bar of my whole phone changed to
match the theme on their site which is
something mobile developers can do now
with Chrome never came across that until
today I asleep keep messing with the
quick settings all the time since I use
them more and more every day and I keep
finding new functionality and new
clickable things that happen when you
press buttons one really nice touch
which you'll discover like day one is
the quick settings disappear when you're
changing the brightness to give you a
preview of the change you're about to
make to what's underneath similar to iOS
8 very nice and there are so many
clickable parts to the quick settings
now that you can basically get to almost
any setting you want in one or two taps
at a time which makes it very fast to
use the phone and I've learned all these
things really just with a couple of days
of using it there aren't so many big
screen optimizations in Android 5.0 like
you might find in a skinned version of
Android Google keeps their design
language very universal so they they
don't build things in that you wouldn't
also want to see
on a 4-inch phone another pretty unique
new feature is called ambient display
which takes advantage of the o LED
display to show your notifications
instead of an LED light and basically
the way it works is when you pick up the
phone it'll show you your clock and a
black and white version of any of the
notifications you have waiting for you
it's a very sleek way doesn't use much
battery at all kind of pulses in a
subtle way and then you can touch the
screen to bring them all to color and
interact with them without ever touching
the power button so it's not quite the
same as tapped awake but since it
requires you to pick up your phone to
get it going it's a little bit of an
extra step but I kind of like it and
since it's just a software feature
theoretically it can be improved with
software updates and keep getting better
but we really notice is all these
animations everywhere and I did a
separate video an entire video review of
Android 5.0 lollipop and all its
features and what's new and what's
awesome so I'll leave a link to that
right below that like button if you want
to check it out I talked about all these
animations a lot I think that video
makes a really good companion to the
nexus review the thing about performance
on this Nexus 6 is there's these
animations all over the place in Android
5.0 and those animations are smooth and
they move at a really high frame rate so
it feels like the phone is moving very
well but if you take a step back and
look at overall performance it's not all
that much better than other phones and
it's actually even though it benchmarks
higher than a lot of other phones it
doesn't perform better than a lot of
those phones and again this is mostly
because it has all those pixels to push
on that quad HD display the overall feel
of the OS is buttery smooth all the way
through and I love that it's just that
sometimes launching applications or you
see this occasional stutter things just
feel like a half a step slow once in a
while and you'll notice that because you
didn't see those same stutters on the
top of the line 1080p phones and it
again feels like that first generation
pod of quiet HD devices the same way we
had that first generation pod of 1080p
devices we're moving up into the
performance of everything else and we'll
soon see it I mean I'm sure software
updates will continue to improve
performance and I tend to be less harsh
on things that I believe can be fixed
with software updates and since it's a
nexus it's first in line for software
updates but again in terms of
performance it's very very smooth as you
would expect out of stock Android just
don't expect it to blow your mind in
terms of being better just because the
benchmark score is so high now being
huge also
gives you all the x-ray advantages of
having all that extra space inside and
one of them is that huge battery space
so the Nexus 6 at ten and a half
millimeters thick with all those curves
has room inside for a thirty two hundred
million power cell so the battery life
on the Nexus 6 you would expect I guess
with Android 5.0 peer stock project
Volta the Android runtime and a 3200
milliamp hour battery you would expect
that with all that this phone should set
a new standard for how long phones
should last in your pocket not this one
we are clearly still in that first
generation of quad HD phones where
basically all smartphones tend to be in
this sort of a bubble of roughly average
battery life and then quad HD phones are
over here sort of moving up into this
level over the next couple of months but
we're still in that first generation and
the Nexus 6 battery life is average at
best now my usage isn't the same as
everyone else but just to give a number
my average screen on time at the end of
the day after one charge with this guy
was about three to three-and-a-half
hours of use where with a 1080p stock
Android phone like the oneplus one I use
for a couple months I would get more
like four to four and a half hours of
screen on time so it'll still last me an
entire day I'll usually dip into the
last 15 percent of the battery at the
end of every single day so it's not like
I have plenty of battery to spare but
it's a quad HD phone and it clearly
suffers from having all those extra
pixels to push around in the battery
life Department now it does have a no
LED display and you can save battery
there and it has a pretty good standby
time so if you have a light usage day
you'll be totally fine but the main way
that they essentially remedy this is by
having turbo charging this is a Motorola
device so it came with the Motorola
turbo charger which is essentially just
a higher amperage version of a regular
charger that this will accept any cable
will work and it worked really well it
did get pretty warm while turbo charging
but I don't think that harms the battery
at all and I'd be surprised by how much
charge I could get back by just a couple
of minutes of being plugged in so if I
had a particularly heavy day and I
happen to be back near the charger
before the end of the day and I want to
juice up real quick just to make sure I
get enough the turbo charging worked
fantastic and at least that was a bright
side of that also I could swear that the
Nexus 6 is supposed to support wireless
charging qi wireless charging
but as much as I tried in as much as I
tried to Finnick around with the Nexus 5
Qi wireless charger from last year's
model I could never get it to recognize
it or charge at all so maybe I'm gonna
have to buy another charger maybe
they'll release another Nexus charger
this year but couldn't get that to work
there's also a battery saver mode that
disables a bunch of radios and limits
performance and things like that
to get you the most editor last 15% or
so of your battery but I almost avoided
using it since the animations all got
super choppy when you limit performance
so I'd rather just pop in the charger
for a few minutes and charge up overall
battery grade for the Nexus 6
I'd give it something like a c-plus but
again if you grade it on a curve and
compare it to all the other quad HD
phones the note 4 would get that a plus
and then Nexus 6 would get something
like a B+ also connectivity on this
phone is something that's done really
well surprisingly well even though it's
a little thing if you're an 18 T
customer like I am stick your nano SIM
in the top and you have all your bends
get to go plug and play you're a
t-mobile customer stick your nano SIM in
you're good to go all your bends
plug-and-play you have cellular customer
same thing if you're a Verizon customer
same thing this is plug and play with a
Verizon nano SIM 2 and it has all those
bands which is probably the best way to
do it because we all saw what happens
when you try to work with Verizon for
Nexus now cameras and Nexus phones have
never really been a strong suit to put
it lightly there's hope for it every
year and it does get better each time
but it's never really an A+ camera this
time it's Motorola Stern to give it a
shot and I basically like I said it's a
blown-up Moto X so you're looking at the
same 13 megapixel sensor here with a
ringed diffuser around an LED flash on
the back plus that extra space inside is
enough room to add optical image
stabilization so the software to take
photos is great it's very very fast
getting back to the Galaxy Nexus roots
of a near-instant shutter at least in
decent light but it seems to have some
focusing problems in less than decent
light so sometimes I'd tap to take a
picture and then it would totally re
hunt to find focus again and then snap
but overall taking photos on the huge
crispy bright viewfinder hard to
complain about that so with the photos
themselves the camera is actually better
than the Nexus 5 which is good it should
be and the colors look really good the
sharpness is on point and it's a pretty
decent image most of the time so
thumbs up there it's fun because it
actually looks really really good when
you're taking it on the phone on looking
it on that awesome display but when you
take it back to the computer and blow it
up and really inspect them I can see
some of that Motorola image processing
and a little bit of softness but overall
I'm impressed to say the least that this
isn't a disappointing camera anymore at
all there are still a few gripes though
tap to expose for one thing was super
aggressive so if you tap to expose on a
dark area it's going to blow out your
highlights with a hot exposure but vice
versa is true too so if you tap on a
bright area to expose you lose all of
your shadows in darkness so you really
want to be careful where you choose to
tap to expose with this camera because
the dynamic range is not that great and
depending on where you tap you can end
up with two totally different images but
hey you still have HDR Plus which is
great and works very well and we also
still have those other features in the
Google camera that people tend to forget
about like the panorama mode which keeps
getting better and better it's getting
better at not only taking pictures but
stitching them together without any
flaws so I'm often impressed with the
results here and photo spheres which are
still really cool and I'll actually
upload this one here to Google+ and link
it in the description too I think it
looks really good and you can basically
stand where I stood while looking at the
photo
kind of like the bubble in Google
Streetview but overall you have photos
and videos from the Nexus 6 were pretty
good way better than just acceptable so
that made me happy it shoots 4k video
too and still has optical image
stabilization so that was great even
though it still had some focus hunting
problems once in a while and there's no
HDR for video obviously so the dynamic
range is limited again but overall it's
good to have and a welcome addition and
the photos in anything but the lowest of
low light were very shareable and
pleasant to the eye so I give the camera
the most improved award especially
compared to other nexuses so good job
Motorola also I am super ready for the
raw photo capabilities whenever they
arrive so at the end of the day overall
yes this is a nexus but we got to keep
in mind that this is still a huge quad
HD Moto X running stock Android that's
the TL DW of this video and if you like
that if you like that idea or that
concept then you'll love this phone and
the thing is this isn't this isn't the
best quad HD phone right now I will give
that crown to the Galaxy Note 4 with a
better display a better
battery life and overall very similar
specs but you have to deal with TouchWiz
on the Galaxy Note 4 and that software
is not my favorite in the way it looks
at the way the way it acts and feels so
Android 5.0 here is stock and when you
get Android 5.0 on the note 4 it's not
really going to look like this basically
you have to be really into software and
really want Android 5.0 in order to
justify this one being a better buy it
is a little bit less expensive too it's
six hundred and forty nine dollars to
start which is marginally better than
some other really high-end phones like
this but this is a phone for the Android
heads the Android purists who don't mind
moving to the larger display even if you
don't get any extra optimizations or any
crazy bells and whistle features this is
for the people who are really into it
for stock Android and if you're into it
for that this is the best phone you can
buy right now no regrets right there but
again there are plenty of other choices
out there for you to decide between I am
comfortable making this my daily driver
at least for now well I think it's one
of the best software experiences on any
phone right now but that might change
and I will certainly have videos on
other phones coming up of tees other
things already that I'm working on right
now but that's basically it that's the
Nexus 6 so thanks for watching I hope
you enjoy feel free to subscribe if you
want to see more videos like this and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
bass
you